HYT DERR ITHF
LET'S GO OUT FRONT.
OUT FRONT NIGH PUTINNGE.
RUSSIAN AUTHORITIES TONIGHT
ANNOUNCIHEOP
CRIMESIA.
TRIMEA
INSIDE UKRAINE.FORUS TROOPS
THE EIGHT PEOPLE W
IN CUSTODY ASE CIZETW
UKRAINIANS, D  OF
G THAT ALL
THESS HELP
UKRAINIA 25  OEXPLOSIVES TO TH
NOW, THE FSB T
T THEYENCLES GNGIS XAYTH.S E TR.
T BRIDG
SEETHERE ARE THPLOSIVES THAT
DE.
THAT THEN ADNTO
ERENT TRK,
RUSSIA.
D T TRUC
TIY TO THE
BR CALLING THIS ENTIRE
INVESTIGATION BY RUSSINONSENSE.
E GOING  TAKYOE BY
R WHAT COULVE
INVESTIGATOR WHO IS RU
MEDEOW,
MENTIONED THEORIES OHO
BRIDGE BLEW UP BECAUOF THE EXPL
EXPLIO A REASOFO URDING TO UKRA.
E MINISTRY, HAD E BOTH HER LEGD
TODAY.
NICWALS FT'BREY
.
WHAT IS THE LATEND
>> Reporter: HORRIFYING SCENES
SPT LTMANY I. AHIS WAGH THE NEAY
OF OFTEN R
BOMBARDMENT.
ITEEA HALLMARK, FRANKLY,
S INVASION O
OTTHPORIZH
OBLAST HIT BSHELLS,
NIANOFFICIALS.
OVDAYS WE'VE
SEEN AN INTENSIFICATION OF
CRUI STRIKESY
RUSSIA.
BUT WHAT WE'VE BEEN SEEING
IS REALLY THE HALLMARKR
PRESENCE HE, FRANKLYISTENTOMAN
ES RUSSIA'S
MILITARILY SOE HITTING BACK A
AREAS ANTURE.
THE ADVANCES IN
LEMENTS BEINBERATED
UKRAINIAN ES
RE PUSHINGROUND THE TOP  CITLLET
ADDING PSSURE TO IT.
ANBACKDROP TO ALL OFS
AWFUL BOMBARDMENT THATE' SEEINGM
RUSSIAE LEADING
YESTERDAYSAYING IT'O TALKWEE
AD TALK BU'T
RE SERIOUS OFFER YET.TODA
HOG T THE POSSIBILITY OF
AT THEESAND KYIV
USSIA AT THEGO USE
AUSE TO COAR
OBJECTIVES.
BUHEARING A T FROM
BLAMING OTHERS FENG.S HIS TURKI
>> THANK YOU VERY ND TONIGHT.
A IS BLA R ATK ON A KEYPP, WHIC.
BUT H IS IT'
SO WHAT REALLY HAPPENED?
OREN LIEBERMANT ter: FRO, SURVE
>> THERE ARE OTHERIABLES PUTD
TO THEIXICANT THAT
THOND AT E RIGH
OW QUALITYE
VIDEY FRAMAT
THE NTASRAISES .M THAT VIDEO
FO WASE THAT
DETONATED ANCA
EXPLOSIVES OR CLOSED
THE DARKNESS ANDE
FIREBALL.
S UNLY E CAME FROM BELOW THE
>> TASWHFECTED THE
T ST
ERE.E'S BEEN SOME SORT O
OVERPRESSURE DEFINITIVELY ONROA.
THERE'S ALSOE CACALL IIFOU OR ,C
IDNDERSIDEF
IDor  LESS PROBABLET INIAN SPECE
CAME FROM A
BRIDGE IS HUNDREDS OMILES FROM
UK
BOATAND ORY SEA.
SOPLANATION IS ITSPROBLEMS.
FLYING HELICRSN AND MARIUPOLTTAL
UKRAINE S
NO DOUBTS THIS IS TE
AT THE DESTRUCTION OF THE  IRA
E OR EXECUTORS STMI
E.orHA AUT KERSH
TO ADD TOLOON>> WE DON'T REALLV
JUO PLIO BRIDGE.
CONTRIBUTE TO THAT.
orr:S
ON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED.
EAY N'HO KERSHRIDGE.
XCDE
RUSSIAN, IT WAS G G INSIDE O US
>> Reporter: BUT EXPAY IT
TO TART R N CRITICALINFRASTUN
PEOPLE HAVEND OVER
ALATS
EXT TYPE, WHAT NLY AMAZING ASTHU
SIZE?
A       T THAT?RE STIIFD ONES T
BEE D
AND MAY NOT BECOME CLEAR.
LD HAV
THREATED THIS BOMB
ULD GET N INSPECTIONS IF THOSEPL
THAT T.
SO PERHAPS A FERTIR , PERHAPS W
IMARONE THING EXPERTS  SEEM TO A
B THAT LENDS
CARRY A BOMB, AND PERHAPS FROM D